[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là on est à versailles donc sur le
plateau de satory et on est dans le
périmètre de la zone d'aménagement
concerté donc satory ouest qui est un
projet d'aménagement qui fait partie des
opérations qui sont portées par
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay il ya tout d'abord donc
l'ambition de créer un quartier qui est
à la pointe en termes de mobilité et au
niveau de l'industrie de la défense est
la deuxième grande ambition de ce projet
là qu'on poursuit c'est de créer un
quartier ville nature où il ya une forte
interpénétration donc de ces deux
éléments là donc l'urbain et le paysage
la biodiversité dans le cadre de cette
ambition de créer un quartier ville
nature l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay je mets en
place
aujourd'hui donc une pépinière de
plantes locales vous savez un projet qui
est soutenu par la région ile de france
et qui qui se fait en collaboration donc
avec la ville de versailles
la communauté d'agglomération versailles
grand parc et l'arboretum de chèvreloup
en est l'objectif de cette pépinière de
plantes locales
c'est de reconstituer donc des milieux
qui existe aujourd'hui sur site dans les
futurs espaces publics du projet de
cette oreille ouest en utilisant des
plans qui sont issus de graines qui sont
récoltées donc sur le site même
j'accompagne l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay pour la
constitution d'une pépinière de plantes
sauvages locales et donc ça débute pas
simplement la récolte de semences donc
des espèces sauvages sur site
donc cette année tout d'abord un plan de
sauvegarde donc des diagnostics des
inventaires pour voir quelles espèces
ont été sauvegardés et puis là on est au
mois de juin donc on est en plein dans
la récolte donc il va durer jusqu'à la
fin de l'été parce qu'il faut nettoyer
les lots enlevait des impuretés et avoir
des semences à ses propres donc ça ça va
à peu près jusqu'à octobre
à l'automne on va semer en fait les
espèces sauvages c'est mieux de les
semer directement à l'automne pour
qu'ils lèvent au printemps prochain 2020
se joignent à peu près 60 espèces 64
espèces si mes souvenirs sont bons et
qui m'ont a inscrit dans ce plan de
sauvegarde
évidemment que c'est un intérêt puisque
ce sont des espèces qui sont adaptés
donc c'est des espèces sauvages locale
donc c'est à dire qu'elles sont elles
sont vraiment adaptées aux sols au
climat et donc elles sont aussi en
relation et toute la faune la flore
c'est le support de vie de plein
d'autres espèces donc travailler avec
des espèces sauvages et bien
effectivement ça permet de maintenir la
diversité la biodiversité